for people who don't understand when
it's broadcast it's easier to cheat
because you can have
it it removes one of the challenges of
cheating which is the one-way
communication from the board to the
engine here the engine can just watch
the broadcast and then all you have to
do is then signals right back uh I mean
that's really I've woken up to this fact
actually uh programmed so setting all
the silly sex toys aside
um I have uh
I have a bunch of these devices so like
of this um is the size of a coin and it
has a high resolution vibration that you
can send so you can just have this in
your pocket it's basically what your
your smartphone has ability to uh
vibrate you can do programmatic
communication through anything Bluetooth
is the easiest so like this made me
wonder like
wait a minute how often does this happen
like at every level of play and you said
this only became a huge concern
for uh at the highest level of play but
then how much cheating is going on at
like the the middle level of play
especially when more money is involved
so in the Game of Poker when like it's
it really
um it really made me think like the
future will have devices like this much
easier to like you will engineer smaller
smaller and smaller devices that have
onboard compute that like
like this is the future I mean I I just
it makes me uh I think probably with all
kinds of cyber security that means the
defense will just have to get started to
get better even with chess it seems like
the security is very clumsy just looking
the scanning of the recent tournament
one thing you'll see is there a lot of
people are talking about whether Hans is
cheated or not the one thing that almost
nobody is doing is actually like trying
to show how it can be done yeah
everyone's basically avoiding that I
think the single biggest reason for that
is simply because it can be done very
easily at like a weekend turn if you
play a weekend tournament where the top
prize is a hundred dollars and the
players are maybe Master Level somebody
could already do this because even in St
Louis now where they have the security
my understanding is the one the um the
non-linear Junction device they bought
cost about eleven thousand dollars
um and organizers if you're if you have
a weekend tournament at the at the local
Club you don't have eleven thousand
dollars to spend on such a device and so
that is why a lot of people have been
talking about it but I think it is very
very serious and it's that's why it is
good even if you know aside from Hans
even it is a very important question or
debate to be having at the present
moment well I think I think it's good to
talk about it right to make it so that
the defenses will really step up I think
you could do pretty cheap like the
security pretty cheaply uh yeah but you
have to you take it seriously right
right of course uh and again we'll we'll
see what happens I think that's gonna
end up being on feed it more than anyone
else to try and do that I I don't think
asking the organizers to do it I mean I
feel like fide they are the governing
body it will be on them at the end of
the day to figure it out but it's uh
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens in the next couple of months